this is the Jocko underground podcast
number 28 sitting here with Echo Charlie
yes and I was I got something to discuss
broadly that I think is helpful
all right here's here's here's what I'm
discussing broadly I'm not aiming this
at you
kind of yeah I'm kind of aiming it at
everyone including myself yeah right
here's the deal you're not right
okay you're not right
so don't act like you're right
and don't walk around like you're right
and don't treat other people like you're
right
I I see this this quite a bit sometimes
I see it for myself disappointing
where you think you're right I think I'm
right you think you're right we think
we're right yeah
and we're not it's kind of like
if you start to pull the the layers back
it's like Jiu Jitsu hate to say it but
true you remember how kind of badass you
were you thought you were
when you never trained it before
yeah I know what you're saying you
thought you were right kind of yeah and
then the first class maybe even the
first class you're like oh once I learn
a couple things then I'm gonna know
everything
kind of I can see how that would be the
case but my unique experience did not oh
really you're out of the gate yeah I got
beat down pretty pretty continuously but
what about prior to getting beat down oh
no yeah you're right yeah then you
thought you knew everything like you can
handle this yeah yeah uh actually I Was
Daryl Cooper DC sure he was he was
saying that he he did the Martyr made
podcast the first six it's something
like I don't know what are they two or
three hours each so there's
I don't know between 12 and 20 hours of
him talking about the
israeli-palestinian conflict
and he said he after he read like three
books on it he was like oh yeah I know
it now and then he's kept reading and
you get different perspectives different
perspectives different perspectives
different perspectives
and that's what the that's the way it is
in the world and right now a lot of
people walk around
thinking they know things thinking they
know things
I do this I think I know something
and what I'm trying to say is nobody
knows
but here's what's beneficial about this
this attitude
of accepting that not everyone knows
everything
is that I don't get mad when somebody
thinks they know it doesn't bother me
you know because you can let that bother
you when someone says No it should be
like this and you know you know they
don't know there's no way they could
know
and I think this is leading to a lot of
the divisiveness in the country in the
world
because everybody thinks they know and
then they think they back it up
with
experts or science the science one's a
big one
both both sides of every argument the
sign says this well guess what I can
find you some signs it says something
else and I'm not just talking about Echo
Charles Bro Science
[__] I'm talking science and guess what
science changes
you ever seen those
newspaper clippings or old articles
would that say the opposite of what's
Happening Now Well there I saw one that
was Ice Age is coming this is 1973 or
something next ice age is coming World
temperatures are dropping or you see the
Articles or the advertisements back
there or even articles that said how
smoking tobacco is good for you these
are the benefits
science changes
but people act like they know with no
caveat whatsoever
and that will drive a person crazy it
will drive you crazy it will drive me
crazy if I get if you say something and
I S I think Echo thinks she knows it I
just go now Echo thinks he knows it but
he doesn't so that's fine
articles journals
right it was in a journal okay so that
means you're right yeah it's not true
so let's just put a caveat on things and
say this is what I think right now but I
could be wrong
and if you approach people like that and
you approach ideas like that you're
probably going to have an easier time
you're probably going to be able to or
you're probably going to be able to
articulate yourself better you're
probably going to have a more open mind
you're going to have a better it ends up
being an indirect approach when you
discuss things with people instead of
saying that's not the way it works you
say oh I haven't heard that perspective
before please inform me more yeah
but and what's really weird you start
throwing social media into this stuff
it's just a Minefield it's a disaster
because now not only do I think I know
something but I'm gonna tell the world
that I know it
[Laughter]
and then they're all gonna pile on and
tell me why I'm wrong
and attack me and attack my ideas
so
we don't know anything leave yourself
some room to maneuver yeah you don't
there's nothing that you can be certain
about or let me rephrase that there are
very few things you can be certain about
so don't run around
thinking you're certain about everything
yeah because it doesn't help you
yeah it doesn't help you move through
the world
yeah and a lot of people misuse the word
science as well
did I
did no no
no
look at that taco hey I could be wrong I
mean you could have misused the word
science it's possible I'm not a
scientist put it this way when I think
when
when people are like hey the science the
science of the science right
so you can well I mean you got to kind
of consider what scientific method is
there's like it's a very specific method
okay which is of course it's not like
perfect I guess theoretically it's
perfect but it's not perfect because
no it's not perfect exactly yeah it's
like the same point right so it's closed
so the part that gets jammed up isn't
necessary necessarily science
it's like how good is the scientist or
group of scientists how good are they at
implementing the scientific method and
then do they even have enough
information to draw any kind of likely
conclusion right and even if they draw a
likely conclusion it's still only likely
yeah but here's the deal look exactly
yeah I I use that but
let's face it I'm just talking about
life stuff right I'm talking about just
general human interaction yeah I think I
know yeah and you don't know yeah you
don't know so leave yourself an open
mind leave yourself a little room to
maneuver leave yourself a little room to
grow and learn and when you have to when
you talk to people
you ask good questions about what their
Viewpoint is and try and understand
their perspective yeah it's gonna make
your whole life better yeah and you know
I guess even my Approach in bringing
this up
well you know you're not right it's like
that's that's sort of I guess I was
maybe I did that for like the shock
value of it right yeah maybe trying to
make an impact or maybe leave a mark
yeah but man awesome oh this is what I'm
really saying
you don't know everything yeah the
person that you're talking to doesn't
know everything doesn't know anything
100 and they may act like it don't get
mad at them yeah don't get mad at them
just think oh yeah this person thinks
it's helped me it's helped me discuss
things with people and I go yeah you
know what Echo thinks he's 100 right and
I get it right I I I'm empathetic to his
to his attitude I get it he thinks that
he's a hundred percent right yeah and he
doesn't unfortunately it's like he knows
not what he does he knows not what he
does right yeah he just thinks he knows
this 100 he doesn't so instead of me
getting defensive and going on the
attack how about I listen to what you
have to say ask you some good questions
that maybe open up your mind a little
bit to seeing a different perspective so
maybe we can find some common ground
that's what I'm saying yeah yeah the um
we a lot of it is wrong you you are just
like
understanding it's like you're being
understanding you're being an
understanding person where when you
when you admit to yourself like that you
don't know for sure and actually back to
science thing real quick if you read
like a scientific a for real like
scientific journal or piece or something
they'll never say therefore the ice age
is coming right they'll never say that
it'll be like hey this this is what
happened and this is what it showed and
if we were trying to find out this the
likelihood in this study yeah made it
that this is the likelihood by the time
it gets to Twitter oh no by that time it
gets to Twitter experts in journals have
said the ice age is coming exactly right
and that's actually exactly right and
then that's not to mention like the
study and how good how well it was done
so if they're like oh yeah we had a
sample size of a thousand people and we
did this and they only did it with a
thousand people that lived by the beach
it's like well it kind of you know it
can be skewed in that way and like or
just like the in like an incompetent
group of scientists but they're the only
ones studying it so this is the most
recent study and all this stuff and the
point is you're correct like the science
I mean I don't know if I'd say it in
those words but your point is correct
like the science can change yeah you can
get improved information it's all within
science but yeah improved information
improved conclusion there's all the you
know we we used to think that the
Universe revolved around the earth
exactly that was the science yeah and
the thing is it kind of is because when
you look when you make certain
observations especially if you're the
only one doing it that's what it looks
like that's all the info we have
therefore that's the current conclusion
you know but then you look more into it
more people study it like all different
perspectives as a wise man once said you
see what I'm saying you get to know uh
more more of the information and you and
you start to understand a little bit
more it's just such a much better
approach it's going to be better for
your mental health and I'm no mental
health expert but getting mad getting
mad because Echo just says he's certain
about something or getting mad because
Echo doesn't
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen go
to Jocko underground.com And subscribe
and we're doing this to mitigate our
Reliance on external platforms so we are
not subject to their control and we're
doing it so we can give you more control
more interaction more direct connections
better Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it cost eight
dollars and 18 cents a month and if you
can't afford to support us we can still
support you
general assistance at Jocko
underground.com and we'll get you taken
care of until then we will see you
immobilized
Underground